While Spider-Man: Into the Spider-Verse is
totally suitable for children, it has some
truly great moments that older viewers can
appreciate — moments that likely swung right
over the kiddies' heads.
These are some of the things that only adults
will notice in Into the Spider-Verse.
Into the Spider-Verse feels like a movie that
is fully aware of the fact that it's inspired
by a comic book.
The film begins with an introduction from
Peter Parker… well, a Peter Parker, as we
later meet a couple different versions of
him.
If you pick up on the context clues, you can
determine that the Peter from the beginning
of the film is actually Tobey Maguire's Spider-Man
from the original Sam Raimi trilogy.
The film smartly displays animated versions
of scenes from those movies, including Peter
stopping the runaway train in 2004's Spider-Man
2 and even his weird dance from 2007's Spider-Man 3.
Rumor has it that Sony actually even considered
casting Maguire to voice this version of Parker
before ultimately settling on Chris Pine.
Beyond that, Peter goes on to brag that he's
been featured on a slew of various merchandise,
including a comic book, a cereal …
"And a so-so popsicle.
I mean, I've looked worse."
Doc Ock tentacle slams him into wall.
He also mentions that he has "an excellent
theme song," which fans of the early animated
cartoon shows can certainly vouch for.
While this surplus of Spidey stuff is sure
to give older fans fits of nostalgia, you
have to wonder how much of it went unnoticed
by the younger generation.
After Miles is bit by the radioactive spider,
his body starts to change.
He wakes up the next morning and notices that
his pants are now too short because he grew
in height.
Seeking an explanation, he wonders if he's
possibly going through puberty.
Later, he finds himself noticeably sweating
while trying to pull off Uncle Aaron's "shoulder
touch" pick-up move with Gwen.
When she asks him straight-up why he's so
sweaty, he tells her:
"It's a puberty thing."
He continues to stick with this story throughout
the scene, even when his newly acquired spider-grip
gets stuck in Gwen's hair, causing her to
exclaim, "I don't think you know what puberty
is!"
The scene is humorous to adults because they
know that obviously puberty has nothing to
do with gaining spider powers — and everything
to do with the awkward teenager-ness that
inspired Miles to try out Uncle Aaron's move
in the first place.
However, for a kid who hasn't gone through
puberty, they might not fully grasp the outlandish
nature of Miles' assessment.
If only it truly did grant you superpowers!
Better than acne and B.O., right?
You don't have to be Sherlock Holmes to immediately
figure out that in Into the Spider-Verse,
Miles' Uncle Aaron was going to play an important
role in the young hero's story.
Fans of the comics knew that he was actually
the Prowler, but even if you didn't know that
going in, it became pretty obvious early on
that good ol' Uncle Aaron had a few tricks
up his sleeve.
However, when you consider that this is a
Spider-Man movie, the term "uncle" should
be a red flag.
Everyone knows that it took the death of his
Uncle Ben for Peter Parker to realize that
his actions have consequences, and that he
can't always save everyone.
"Uncle Ben?"
"Peter."
"I'm here, Uncle Ben."
For young Miles, it's the death of his Uncle
Aaron.
The parallel between the two characters is
a brilliant facet of the film that is both
mature and thought-provoking.
“You're on your way.
Just keep going.
Just keep going."
Eagle-eyed audience members most likely picked
up on a hearty portion of the various Easter
eggs featured in Spider-Man: Into the Spider-Verse.
In one of the film's many blink-and-you-miss-it
moments, viewers get a peek at Miles' dad's
phone contacts.
Although Jefferson Davis is trying to call
his brother, Aaron, you can't help but notice
another, more prominent name on the list:
Steve Ditko.
Marvel fanboys will recognize that as a nod
to the late comic book artist who, along with
Stan Lee, co-created Spider-Man and Doctor
Strange.
However, the subtle name-dropping doesn't
stop there.
In another scene, Miles takes out his phone
to make a call, and the audience yet again
gets a glimpse at his phonebook.
The most obvious attention-grabbers are the
names B. Bendis — alluding to Brian Michael
Bendis — and Sara Pichelli.
This duo co-wrote Miles Morales' first series,
2011's Ultimate Comics Spider-Man.
You probably only noticed these subtle details
if names like Ditko, Bendis, and Pichelli
meant something to you, and, for many now-adult
comic readers in the '90s and early 2000s,
that was the case.
When it's finally his turn to return to his
own universe, John Mulaney's Peter Porker,
a.k.a. Spider-Ham, gives Miles a touching
farewell, humorously gifting him a massive
wooden hammer…
"I want you to have this.
It'll fit in your pocket."
… before making the jump home.
Before he ascends, he sadly declares…
"That's all, folks."
… prompting Peter B. Parker to ask if he
was allowed to say that, quote, "legally?"
The line is obviously a reference to the Looney
Tunes character Porky Pig, owned by Warner
Bros. — who you can assume has a trademark
on the infamous phrase.
By questioning the legality of using the line,
Peter breaks the fourth wall to call the audience's
attention to the cartoon pig that isn't Porky
saying his famous line.
It's a meta nod to a competitor's classic
character, but its humor is probably lost
on children, since, well… they probably
aren't all too familiar with the concept of
copyright infringement.
Into the Spider-Verse really starts to gain
traction when Peter B. Parker enters the fold
— a chubbier, more depressed Spider-Man
than the one from Miles' universe.
During his introductory scene, the audience
learns that this more jaded, broken-down version
of Peter ended things with the Mary Jane from
his universe because, well…
"She wanted kids, and… it scared me."
Although it's presented in a humorous light,
this arc of Peter learning that he can, in
fact, become a good parent is present throughout
the movie, for those clever enough to pick
up on it.
It doesn't take a rocket scientist to realize
that the relationship between Peter and Miles
is not unlike that of a father and son.
Miles, the in-over-his-head apprentice, seeks
guidance from Peter, the weary master who
is so experienced that he almost can't help
himself from giving advice.
By the end of the movie, Peter gets to witness
firsthand the effect his presence had on Miles'
heroic growth, and it's a feeling that gives
him immense pride.
In the climactic final battle, Peter says…
"I love you.
I'm so proud of you.
Do I want kids?"
Most parents in the audience surely understood
Peter's weighty realization.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.